we've talked about a few different
things so far like market segmentation
and personas and I know your startup so
you just want to get to the bottom line
so where do you start
what do you do first well let's talk to
an expert what does more have to say
about this if I as a start-up I think I
would I think it's best to start with
persona and I think the persona is the
target customer with the compelling
reason to buy and then I think as you
start to engage that that with that
persona and you say you you put out your
app or you put out your downloadable
thing and you're hoping that this
persona will download you new your
communication you use pictures that you
hope look like the person you want and
you say things you hope they want to
hear and then you start seeing how well
they engage with you and sometimes as
you as you watch them engage you realize
I have the wrong person on oh yeah you
know I but this thing is actually
getting traction what's getting traction
with a different group of people so you
say okay well now who maybe that's my
persona right so you have to be willing
to move I think when you start getting
quantitative around the discipline of
segmentations when you want to scale
when you start scaling and you start
saying I'm going to actually make
significant marketing and I'm going to
raise capital somehow and I'm going to
spend that money on marketing now you
you need to have a more analytical
approach to where you're targeting that
money but the beginning I think it's
much more qualitative